Varys: The Maesters tell us that Aegon came
to Westeros with fire and blood, and hammered
six kingdoms into one.
The fire he undoubtedly brought, as the Kings
of the Rock, Reach, and Iron Islands learned.
Aegon's own son, Maegor the Cruel, was killed
by the very Iron Throne his father had forged
if you believe the tales.
If you don't, then perhaps "the Cruel" is
not a wise name for a king to earn.
Daeron, First of His Name, tried to finish
his ancestors' work and bring Dorne into the
fold.
For his efforts, he lost sixty thousand men
and his own life of eighteen years.
During the great Targaryen civil war known
as "the Dance of the Dragons," a king and
queen each vied for the throne, dividing their
house and its dragons against each other.
Eventually, the queen was fed to her rival's
dragon while her son watched, and the victorious
king soon died of his own wounds.
By the war's end, King's Landing was smashed,
cities razed and sacked never to be rebuilt,
and dragons had faded from this world.
Jaime Lannister: For centuries, the Kingsguard
have been the glory of the realm.
Aegon the Conqueror had established the order
as his personal guardians after uniting Westeros
with fire and blood.
He knew that some of his subjects wouldn't
take to conquest, and his dragons were no
use against knives in the dark.
No doubt surrounding himself with the greatest
knights in Westeros made his rule more palatable
and less foreign as well.
Everyone in his kingdoms soon knew the names
and some of the songs of the Kingsguard.
I certainly did from earliest days.
Bronn: There was one Kingsguard (I forgot
the bastard's name) who swore an oath to his
dying Targaryen king to crown his daughter
after him.
The very night that king died, this Kingsguard
crowned the king's son instead.
When an old man on the Small Council dared
to protest, this honorable knight opened his
throat.
The bastard died in the very civil war he
started along with the old king's son, daughter,
and most of their dragons.
And the Kingsguard?
All that duty and honor and not enough brains
to figure out which Targaryen to give it to.
Twin brothers even ended up on opposite sides,
died with tears on their cheeks as they cut
each other down.
I suppose I should think that's tragic, but
stupid men do stupid things every day and
nobody cries over them.
Petyr Baelish: As little more than a boy,
Ser Criston Cole replaced the legendary Ser
Ryam Redwyne on the Kingsguard and soon rose
to Lord Commander.
But knights only know one way to settle disputes.
When Prince Aegon's father died, Ser Criston
slit the throat of an advisor who objected
to Aegon's ascension over his aunt, the anointed
heir.
His actions so pleased the new King, Aegon,
Second of His Name, that he appointed Ser
Criston as his Hand in the ensuing civil war
called the Dance of Dragons.
Neither Ser Criston nor the King nor even
the Targaryen dragons would survive it.
Viserys Targaryen: The Targaryen dynasty united
the Seven Kingdoms and lasted nearly three
centuries.
It was a dynasty forged in fire, sealed in
blood, and destroyed by rebellion.
The Targaryens are blood of the dragon, descended
from the nobility of ancient Valyria, a once-mighty
empire in the east.
When the cataclysmic Doom laid waste of Valyria
and its people, the Targaryens survived, having
settled in the island fortress of Dragonstone
years before.
They remained there for a century until the
rise of Aegon the Conqueror.
Instead of attempting to reclaim the eastern
lands of his ancestors, Aegon sailed west
for the Seven Kingdoms, his sisters Visenya
and Rhaenys at his side.
To keep the bloodlines pure, Aegon continued
the custom of his Valyrian ancestors and took
both of his sisters to wives.
Together, they came ashore on the eastern
coast of Westeros.
Their blazon: a dragon with three heads, representing
Aegon and his sister-wives.
Their words: "Fire and Blood."
While their host was small when compared to
the armies of the Seven Kingdoms, Aegon and
his sisters had a secret weapon.
The last of the dragons.
He conquered every kingdom, save Dorne, which
eventually bowed to Targaryen rule a century
later.
He had the swords of his enemies melted down
by the fiery breath of his dragon, Balerion
the Black Dread, and forged into the Iron
Throne.
The capital city of King's Landing was built
on the eastern coast, where Aegon and his
sisters first came ashore.
And Aegon ordered the construction of a royal
castle on its highest hill, the Red Keep.
Joffrey Baratheon: Aegon built his castle
of red rock to remind people of the fires
he had roasted his enemies in, so whenever
King's Landing looked up, they'd see the price
of defiance.
He knew the first rule of kings.
Only fear keeps men in line.
Fear and punishment.
Then again, torture chambers are just so private.
Better to punish your enemies where everyone
can see and remember.
Like that Targaryen who forced his nephew
to watch as he fed the boy's traitor mother
to a dragon.
Oh, what I could do with a dragon.
Euron Greyjoy: The stories claimed that the
Old Way died with Harren the Black and his
sons in Harrenhal.
Our ships and axes were no match for Aegon's
dragons, so our ancestors bent their steel
into fishhooks and our kingdom into villages
and started telling the red tales around the
fire of how we used to be strong and how one
day we would be so again.
Generations later, a young boy listened to
them.
Dalton Greyjoy, the wild young heir to Pyke,
was rowing at five and reaving at ten in the
Basilisk Isles with his uncle.
By fourteen, Dalton had sailed as far as Old
Ghis, fought in a dozen battles, and claimed
four salt wives.
In his fifteenth year, he avenged his uncle's
death in battle, but he took a dozen wounds
and emerged from the fight drenched head to
heel in blood.
From that day forth, men called him the Red
Kraken.
During the Dance of Dragons, the Red Kraken
picked the side that was fighting the Lannisters
and fell upon the Westerlands while the Lannisters
were off at war.
Casterly Rock itself proved too strong once
the lady of the castle barred its gates, but
the ironborn burned the Lannister fleet and
sacked Lannisport carrying off gold, grain,
and hundreds of women and girls, including
Lord Lannister's favorite mistress and all
his bastards.
The Red Kraken now ruled the Sunset Sea as
his forbears had, and his longships again
brought the Old Way to the coast of Westeros.
But then the war ended, and the mainland armies
came home.
The Iron Throne commanded the Red Kraken to
stop reaving, and when he didn't, a mistress
opened his throat as he slept.
While his sons squabbled, the Lannisters sent
their soldiers to the Iron Islands.
Thousands of men, women, and children were
put to the sword, and scores of villages and
hundreds of longships were put to the torch.
The glorious return to the Old Way had lasted
almost two years.
Varys: In its time, the Dragonpit was a marvel
of the world.
Full-grown Targaryen dragons nested beneath
its massive dome, and even on the darkest
nights, the walls seemed to glow with the
fire of the great beasts inside.
Qyburn: As had the site's previous occupant,
the Sept of Remembrance, when Maegor the Cruel
blasted it with dragonfire during morning
prayers.
The screams of the dying men echoed through
King's Landing all day, and a pall of ash
and smoke hung over the city for a week.
Varys: But as it dissipated, so too did the
rebellion of the Faith Militant.
The Sept of Remembrance faded from memory,
and Maegor decided to replace a monument to
the gods with a monument to his family: the
Dragonpit.
Qyburn: Labor proved elusive, however, for
after the Red Keep was finished, Maegor had
hosted a three-day feast for all builders,
stonemasons, and carpenters who had worked
to build it.
At its conclusion, he slaughtered them, so
that only he would know the castle's secrets.
So many men fled the construction of the Dragonpit
that Maegor was forced to employ the prisoners
of the city dungeons, supplemented by skilled
and ignorant builders from across the Narrow
Sea.
Varys: For more than a century, the Targaryens
housed their dragons in the Dragonpit.
But dragons are not horsesto be stabled or
hounds to be kenneled.
With each generation, the dragons became less.
Less massive, less swift, less long-lived.
Qyburn: And less invulnerable.
During the Dance of Dragons, two Targaryen
factions killed a handful of their family's
dragons while fighting each other.
A frenzied mob even broke into the Dragonpit
and slaughtered the five dragons chained there,
though the last managed to bring down the
roof of the great dome on its assailants.
The dragons never recovered their former strength
or numbers.
Perhaps their line had been too broken, or
perhaps others intervened to break it further.
But the last dragon grew no larger than a
cat, and its death earned Aegon, Third of
His Name, the epithet "Dragonbane."